هل لاحظتم عند جلوسكم في احدى امسيات
الصيف ان البعوض يلسع بعضا من الجالسين
ويبتعد عن البعض الاخر السبب يبدو ان
الامر مرتبط بالحمض
النووي لماذا تختارك البعوضه درس باحثون
في لندن طبيعه التوائم المطابقين وغير
المطابقين الذين لا يحملون نفس الحمض
النووي وحين تم تعريض التوام غير المطابق
للسعات البعوض حصلوا على كميات مختلفه من
تلك اللسعات اي انها لم تكن متشابهه ولكن
حين تم اجراء نفس التجربه مع التوام
المطابق تبين ان الاثنين لسع بنفس الطريقه
ونفس الكميه فما الذي يجري هنا يقول
الباحثون ان الامر يتعلق بطريقه الشم لدى
كل شخص لذا تم تغليف اجساد التوام المطابق
بورق القصدير لاجراء فحوصات على رائحه
الجسم وتحليل الاسباب التي تجعل بعض
الروائح مفضله لضى البعوض لذا يوما ما قد
يتمكن الشخص الذي يجذب البعوض من تنا عقار
معين يجعل رائحته غير محببه لهذه
الحشرات